reaching the ministerial coal by using
personal emails to share sensitive
government information so I asked the
minister today how many strikes before
she's out
[Applause]
thank you Mr Speaker
um the right honorable lady has uh made
a number of contentions there and I'm
not Mr Speaker going to get into uh
speculation about uh the events in
question
um the original lady will have heard the
Prime Minister being very clear
yesterday he was uh informed of these
issues uh whilst uh on service of the
country in Tokyo G7 uh he was in Japan
at the G7 uh he has returned from the G7
he is gathering the information what you
know of the Prime Minister is that he
will deal with these issues properly and
professionally but the first point of
that is to gather the information
required on which he can take a view and
that is what he's doing sir Jeremy
Wright
my right honorable friend will recall
that the committee on stands in public
life when I was a member of it
recommended that the independent advisor
should be able to initiate their own
inquiries into breaches of the
ministerial Cove should be able to
determine whether there was a breach
leaving of course properly sanctions for
the prime minister to determine that has
several advantages it gives the benefit
of a decision being taken at arm's
length from government and if I may say
to my right honorable friend it would
also mean we will have fewer occasions
such as this and he'll have to answer
fewer uqs
[Applause]
thank you uh Mr Speaker
what the honorable judgment says of
course is true it is always a pleasure
to before this house in any
circumstances and to respond to my uh
right honorable friend I I wouldn't wish
us to detract from the fact that the
ministerial code as a prime minister's
document it is as a code as to how the
Prime Minister expects his uh ministers
or her ministers to behave in a set of
circumstances the prime minister is the
ultimate judge of that uh ministerial
code I believe the First Independent
advisor was appointed in 2006 uh to have
a role to support the prime minister in
that function and I think we must recall
uh and remind ourselves it is actually
uh the ministerial code is a prime
minister's document and he needs to be
able to take decisions on the back of it
regarding his ministerial team SMP
spokesperson Kirsten Blackman thank you
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker this is a descent
into absolute farce instead of
professionalism accountability and
integrity that the Prime Minister
promised when he came into office we are
faced with Calamity chaos and Corruption
the MP for Oxbridge continues to be
investigated the MP for stratford-upon
even had to leave cabinet in disgrace
and we are seeing revelation after a
revelation about the misdeeds and
wrongdoings of the Home Secretary first
the request to organize a personal speed
awareness course and today the
Revelation that the Home Secretary did
not disclose her extensive work with the
Africa Justice Foundation 19 alumni of
which are now in senior positions in the
Rwandan government Mr Speaker how can
the Prime Minister continue to pretend
that is presiding over a government with
anything other than their own personal
interests at heart isn't it the case
that the people of Scotland are indeed
all the people of these Isles would be
better served by politicians who
actually understand and stick to the
principles of public life and the
ministerial code will the Prime Minister
ensure an investigation is undertaken
into all of the alleged ministerial code
breaches Mr Speaker what is the point in
having a ministerial court if ministers
simply ignored it minister
thank you Mr Speaker as I said earlier
Mr Speaker there is information being
gathered and that will be the first
point to determine uh the next steps uh
Beyond this
um I I do
um it's always interesting though to
hear from the uh SNP about uh classical
situations with ethics and the one
advantage of a camper van is I suppose
it doesn't go very fast
sir Julian Lewis
thank you Mr Speaker
I have no first-hand knowledge of this
particular case but does my right
honorable friend the minister agree with
me that there is and should always be a
difference between asking a civil
servant to do something which may or may
not be wrong and asking a civil servant
for advice on whether something is or is
not likely to be wrong if you do it yes
minister
i i i Mr Speaker of course I would agree
that there is a difference there but I
wouldn't wish to speculate about this
particular circumstance as my my
honorable friend will understand
Lloyd Russell Moyle thank you Mr Speaker
if the prime minister is gathering the
evidence he is asking for more
information
what is so wrong with just launching an
investigation properly through the
correct channels
there's nothing incorrect with the
process which has been conducted
properly and professionally the Prime
Minister will gather the information and
then decide next steps it's very simple
Charles Walker you could have an
admission to make the Home Secretary is
not on my Christmas card list and I'm
certainly not on hers and I hope this is
a question not a statement but I find it
hard to get my head around the fact that
the BBC sent its political editor
halfway across the world to a G7
conference Summit where we were
discussing energy security
Ukraine defense to ask our prime
minister a question about a speed
awareness course this is the question
why why he's got no do it
as my right honorable friend is well
aware the BBC is editorally completely
independent
foreign
but I absolutely hear what he says
hello Reeves
faram was the Attorney General she
tweeted her support
Dominic Cummings driving to Bernard
Castle to test his eyesight when she was
home secretary under Liz trust she was
sacked for sending sensitive government
government information from a personal
email address and as home secretary
under Rishi soon actually faces
allegations of instructing civil
servants to arrange a private speed
awareness course every step of the way
it's one rule for members of this
government and another for everyone else
what will it finally take to get an
investigation
[Applause]
uh an investigation will be dependent on
the information gathered the Prime
Minister will get that information he'll
take a decision on the back of the
information that he has received
in recent weeks the Home Secretary has
publicly supported the majority of you
the immigration levels are too high in
this country and she's led the debate on
how we can reduce overall migration
numbers given that 6 000 people are
convicted of speeding every day and like
the majority of people the Home
Secretary has paid the fine and taken
the points does my honorable friend
agree with me that this league is a
clear attempt to play the woman not the
ball an attempt that undermines our
democracy and distracts from the
important job of delivering on ordinary
people's priorities
Minister the Home Secretary has an
incredibly important job to do I totally
agree with my uh honorable friend and I
know she's deeply committed whatever the
law is to get on and deliver that job
for the uh for the British people
um of the information will be gathered
but I know that the Home Secretary is
deeply committed to that task and will
continue to do
well the ethics advisor is that the sole
discretion of the Prime Minister
the inquiries are carried out are the so
distressing that the Prime Minister
actions taken on the outcome of the
airport are the sole discretion of the
Prime Minister do you think maybe
there's a problem with this process
[Laughter]
um certainly The Honorable gentleman is
aware that the an independent advisor
can recommend the Prime Minister that a
particular uh course of action uh is is
taken although ultimately uh the Old
Gentleman is right uh that the
ministerial code is a matter for the
Prime Minister it is his code and he has
to determine uh the standards expected
of ministers in his or her government
Mr edwardly what's wrong with this
country we used to have proper scandals
about sex or money
or about prime ministers invading Iraq
on dodgy evidence in which hundreds of
thousands of people die apparently this
is a scandal always moral outrage is
ludicrous that a minister asked her
private office about something and she
takes their advice what's happened to
the osmotherly rules we all know what's
this all about they're attacking a good
home secretary so trying to attack the
real Scandal of mass immigration to this
country give us a ball
minister
I
thank my our normal friend for the
question there is a a nine to somebody's
saying but there are is this all a storm
in the feed cup is the question being
asked uh by uh my original friend let
the information will be gathered by the
Prime Minister as I said earlier to my
honorable friend uh whatever that
process I know that the Home Secretary
is deeply committed to continue to
deliver on the on her uh incredibly
important work of delivering for the
British people
speaker the Prime Minister promised
Integrity professionalism and
accountability I think the first two
will agree being shot long ago even
before this latest incident in terms of
accountability he has now taken personal
responsibility for this but I think the
real accountability I'm sure the
honorable member on the front bed would
agree is now down to the British people
at the next general election which can't
come any is sooner at least come sooner
rather than later
[Music]
the British people will know that the
Prime Minister will act in a
professional and proper manner he always
does and he's doing so in these
circumstances I believe I believe it's
not totally unknown for the labor party
to have issues that they need to look
out of a disciplinary uh nature and I
dare so they have processes we too have
processes and will make certain the
Prime Minister will make certain having
gathered the information that he does
what he feels is right for next
speaker I'm my honorable friend for
brocksville makes the right point about
the BBC's political editor but here we
have 50 members or so of the opposition
choosing to spend their time debating
this question does my quite honorable
fan think that they're they're and we
and we've come we've been called out and
we've been called out in defense
and Mr Speaker we are called out in
defense of the government does the
minister think that their constituents
will be proud of the way their their
represented are using their time
[Applause]
Mr Speaker
I have a I have a long memory and I do
recall a little while ago an urgent
question being asked by uh by member of
the House earned the right honorable
lady coming here uh to defend the labor
party's actions amongst other things on
uh the matter of Sue gray and an
appointment and I remember the right
honorable lady saying what a complete
waste of time it was for this Parliament
that we were spending our time wasting
our time on these issues I think my
honorable friend raises a very pertinent
point
Christian jaldi
very much Mr Speaker in the time that
the prime minister is taking to decide
what to do about the home secretary's
actions any of us could have taken a
speed awareness test 17 times and
Counting
so does the minister agree with me that
this to the public looks like weak
leadership and leaves the prime
minister's commitment to Integrity
accountability and professionalism just
an empty promise
uh this prime minister does things
properly and professionally it's right
that he gets the information and he
bases decisions on the information he
does that as prime minister on the whole
remit of government policy it's quite
right that he should do it on this
circumstance as well
yeah Mr Speaker does manual friend agree
with me that once this nonsense has been
dealt with that we should be asking why
when and how this was leaked because
there is also a civil service code to be
adhere to yeah yeah
the guy I um
I thank my honorable friend right now
the focus is on Gathering the
information the Prime Minister needs to
take a decision on this uh but I do
thank him for his intervention clearly
it's always a matter of concern when
information
um uh gets out which um in unauthorized
ways unauthorized circumstances but I
would say the focus now is on just
gathering this information
thank you Mr Speaker this is not about
just a a speeding fine this is about the
Integrity of the Home Secretary and how
she behaved to officials when she was
when she received that fine so did the
cabinet office inform the Prime Minister
about the email sent to the propriety
and ethics team regarding the request
for a private speeding course
the Prime Minister now is asking for the
information that is pertinent to this
and he'll take decisions on the basis of
the information that he receives
goodness thank you Mr Speaker the people
of Stoke-on-Trent North kids Grove and
talk are more interested in how the Home
Secretary is going to empty the hotels
that are being used right now
undermining 56 million pounds of
leveling up funding with economic
migrants and assigned Seekers interested
in how to use the 330 brand new police
officers that have been recruited to
tackle crime and fly tipping in places
like Curry Bridge Thompson smallthorne
are interested in making sure that we
use that 2 million pounds of safer
streets funny that we secured to put new
alley Gates and additional CCTV that is
what they want to see not this Witch
Hunt from the party opposite where their
Prime where the Home Secretary is
already taken accountability by having
Mr goodlis Mr goodlist when I stand up
you sit down once we get that message
we'll understand each other we do want
to get through I think the minister
absolutely got the question even if he's
not responsible for most hard early I
did Mr Speaker my honorable friend
raises an absolutely valuable point but
for his constituents what they are
worried about is a conductor is a condo
out of our policy in relation to a whole
range of issues including their personal
security and migration and a whole list
which the home office has incredibly
important job to do and I know my right
honorable friend the Home Secretary is
absolutely determined to produce those
answers for the British people Williams
they say confession is good for the soul
recently I took a speed awareness course
it was very well taught available at an
early hour so that's it didn't interfere
with my work and available to all
equally why didn't the Home Secretary
Avail herself from this equal
opportunity yeah yeah
I Thank The Honorable I'm better
informed about speed awareness courses
but I'm afraid I'm not going to comment
on the specifics of this circumstance
the prime minister is gathering the
information and then he will take a
decision on the back of that Andrew Gwen
thank you can the minister confirm that
civil servants contacted the cabinet
offices propriety and ethics team about
the home secretary's request and if so
why does he think that the Prime
Minister doesn't have that same
Integrity to ask his ethics advisor to
formally investigate what happened
the Prime Minister was gathering
information to ascertain uh the fact
then he takes a decision on the next
steps from there
thank you Mr Speaker within the last
hour it's been reported by The
Independent Newspaper that the Home
Secretary stands accused of fresh
ministerial code breaches over
undisclosed links to the Rwandan
government as chair of the joint
committee and human rights I've been in
correspondence with the Home Secretary
about well evidenced human rights
concerns in Rwanda and our committee's
concern about the plans to send Asylum
Seekers there the Home Secretary I think
it's fair to say seems to take a rather
rosy-eyed view of rwanda's Human Rights
record does the minister think this has
got anything to do with her undisclosed
links to the Rwandan government and will
he include that potential uh breach of
the ministerial code in in any inquiry
um
The Honorable right honorable unleaded
lady knows more uh than me on this
subject because she's read the full
article I just saw the Tweet um so I I
can't really comment on that I
understand it was something that the
home secretary did with Sherry Blair and
others uh some considerable time ago
before a charitable Endeavor before she
entered Parliament that's just what I
got from the tweet I can't really
comment anymore matters The Honorable uh
lady will understand under McDonald
speak it I received a letter from The
Honorable member for Bishop Auckland to
whom I've given reference to have died
raises today as under Secretary of State
for leveling up in response to the
concerns I've raised in respect to the
activities that tease Works she advised
me that there was nothing untoward at
play although I was not provided
anything made by her but importantly as
she was the reciproc
can I just say I think it might be more
of a point of order rather than actually
in the middle of where we are now I'm
not quite sure to the ministerial court
on this particular minister
right I think we
yeah I know it doesn't say that
okay Mr Speaker because importantly the
minister was the recipient of a properly
declared four-figure donation from a
party directly collected to these
dealings surely she should have recused
herself and in Fairly to do so is in
direct contravention of the ministerial
code of paragraph 7.1 and onwards
doesn't the minister agree
uh Mr Speaker you'll appreciate sir that
I'm not in any position to comment on
the kind of uh allegations that The
Honorable gentleman uh is making I'm not
in a position to make any comments on
that whatsoever I'm that's for another
occasion not sure
can he update the house on the status of
the special advisors code given that the
home secretary's special advisor
apparently lied repeatedly to
journalists are getting clear breach of
the special advisors code and yet the
Prime Minister and the cabinet secretary
have done absolutely nothing that's
right
so could I just say if both gentlemen
went to conversation please take the
notes I'm not across the chimp minister
stuff
Mr Speaker
um in response to the uh radham's
question uh they I think the
entrepreneur will be well aware of the
contents of the special advisors code
which does set out Health special
advisors uh should at in these
circumstances I am not in a position to
talk about the specifics of this case in
these circumstances this is uh early
days the prime minister is gathering
information uh regarding uh regarding
the uh the overall picture and we'll
take decisions in due course Steve
Morgan thank you Mr Speaker does the
minister believe that the Home Secretary
has acted entirely within a ministerial
code while in office
I think it's for the Home Secretary uh
as we say that there are two people but
there are I'm not I said right at the
start of my statement uh Mr Speaker that
there are
the the ministerial code is a matter for
the Prime Minister he is the ultimate
Arbiter on all questions regarding the
ministerial code and it's for individual
ministers to make certain that they
adhere to it uh that is the facts of the
case
bye Kingsbury
thank you Mr Speaker why is the prime
prime minister so weak and indecisive he
can't even refer this Home Secretary to
his independent ethics advisor week week
[Applause]
I don't know if the honorable gentleman
had a chance to be here for the uh
statement yesterday on the G7 what he
would not find from that prime
minister's statement was any suggestion
of weakness you saw a prime minister
who's just come back from the G7 where
he was focused on delivering for the
British people and he went through
yesterday the Litany of achievements
that we have made at that Summit that is
a country that is standing up for itself
on the world stage and that is a prime
minister able to deliver for the people
of this country and that is the main
event
we're in fellows thank you Mr Speaker I
I wonder if the cabinet office minister
is just a wee bit off with the Home
Secretary because he came here to defend
her today and lo and behold here's
another Scandal actually mentioned
earlier by my own right honorable
learned friend how many inquiries does
the minister think the PM's ethics
advisor should be asked to conduct or
should the Home Secretary just resign
and save us all the bother for you
minister
uh whether this is a matter for the
independent advisor will be a matter of
the Prime Minister to determine he is
going to gather that information he will
then take a decision on it
okay Mr Speaker the uh state has
apologized for the spitting has fully
unwillingly can play with the police and
paying the fame NASA's learned on
punishment given in the midst of the
storm created a day lessons hopefully
can be learned does the minister agree
that we can all learn from the biblical
quotation he or she who is without sin
can throw the third Stone
I think Mr Speaker if that is my last
question uh that is a very good point on
which to end this session and I thank my
honorable friend for the question that
he made
thank you Mr Speaker
um at primus's questions on the 19th of
April the Prime Minister claimed that
last year the number of NHS dentists had
increased in England by 500. however
today the British Dental Association has
revealed that the number of dentists
delivering NHS work has actually Fallen
by almost 700 in the 2223 Financial year
I'm sure Mr Speaker that the Prime
Minister did not intentionally aim to
mislead the house